– Geh deinen Weg.
Sag mir, woher du kommst und …
– … wohin du gehst.
Wo ist dein Weg?
– Geh deinen Weg. Sag mir, woher du
kommst und wohin du gehst.
Was ist dein Ziel?
– Nico, das war großartig!
– Super, ganz toll, wirklich!
– Danke!
– Nico, das ist Sarah.
Ich war bei Sarah in Zürich,
als du mich gesucht hast.
– Oh, okay.
Freut mich, dich kennenzulernen.
– Wir wollen jetzt häufiger
so kleine Partys feiern.
Zum Beispiel nächstes Jahr zu Halloween.
– Oh, dann müsst ihr ’ne Menge
Kürbisse besorgen ...
- Ja.
... weil Halloween ohne Kürbisse
kein Halloween ist, oder?
Ich erinner mich:
Wir haben damals im Herbst immer
ganz viele Gerichte
aus Kürbissen gemacht.
Also, zum Beispiel Kürbissuppe,
Kürbiskuchen, Kürbismarmelade,
Kürbismuffins, Kürbisbrot,
Kürbisbier, Kürbis…
– Ja, wir kriegen das schon hin
mit den Kürbissen.
Wo habt ihr denn dieses
Jahr Halloween gefeiert?
– Wir? Wir haben dieses Jahr
überhaupt kein Halloween gefeiert.
– Nee.
– Was? Nächstes Jahr feiert ihr hier!
– Ja!
– Außerdem wollen wir noch
St. Patrick’s Day feiern und Valentinstag.
– Valentinstag find ich ganz gut.
– Mit wem willst du denn
Valentinstag feiern?
– Mit wem ich …?
– Ja.
– Mal sehen.
– Aha …